[Music]
does Elena ever ask you to not eat your
own [__] after sex yeah
yeah
she does yeah Kelsey says the same thing
yeah it's just like I can't
can't what I just can't help it I'm like
yeah I can roll around your stomach yeah
I can't not eat my own [__] I can't stop
she just catches you in the bathroom
[Laughter]
you're like a dog what are you doing
there
yeah yeah
that's what she hears you know when dogs
like just they're looking at you all
cute
and you're like oh look at my boy and
they just start that's so funny dude
every single time Jilly gets me with
that it's the prank that just it just
keeps on giving yeah like he knows it'll
never get old and it never does and I
get pranked every time yeah he looks at
me with those eyes and I'm like you are
the [__] cutest thing on the planet
I love you so I feel such this no it's
like no no it's he waits
and he waits for me to be like I love
you and I kiss him I just have this
undying love for this dog it's like this
this absolute connection that we you
know
and I'm like oh
in the middle of how disrespectful is
that dogs are crazy they'll be [__]
licking their [__] and ass yeah
I like that
I'm like oh come on man yeah
then you're like give me a kiss yeah
yeah and you're like I can't fault you
for that you're so cute and they look at
you again you're like ah okay kiss me in
the mouth yeah yeah I'll kiss you in the
mouth
thanks yeah yeah back to it you know my
dog eats my cat's food
and then he's puking no he just he's
getting like a little bit he used to be
eight pounds he's very spelled very
athletic little dog you know high energy
he still is but we took him to the vet
recently [__] 10 pounds so thick
it's getting a little thick now and I
think it's just because he's been he's
been feasting binge on the kitty Foods
yeah and it's it's always the one he'll
just eat the the one who's timid and
like a little bit reserved will walk in
and she's just waiting behind the bowl
and he's just she's just looking at him
staring at him eating her food that's
gonna be the one that turns out hot
yeah yeah my older brother is always
eating my food so I'm just gonna like
not eat I guess
La hot yeah there you go
you have to be attractive in La you
actually have to be like borderline like
life support yeah my friend
was talking to me he went to Milan to
model okay
um your lawn what
so [__] dumb yeah he needed a place
to shoot so I said Milan yeah right out
front yeah come and shoot them alone
yeah yeah
stupid
you could use me a lot you can use Milan
uh and I was asking him how it was I was
like so how what was Milan like and he
was like dude it's [__] crazy this
guy is what green green as hell yeah
uncamped
no he said he would
he it was just a classic male model [__]
like but you know you're I'm hearing
about it firsthand and he said that they
were ruthless when it came to like
comments about his body yeah he's a
pretty like In-Shape dude he's really in
shape I would say and he said the guys
as soon as he got there the guys were
like um you should eat less sodium
like you're uh maybe and then they told
him not to go to the gym too because
they didn't want too much muscle
on them but they were like pinching
pinching his stomach and be like see
this yeah less sodium
unless you are American you have Burger
all the time right less Burger wow
that's crazy and he would just say he
was standing in a line of other dudes
and they would stand there and they
would like you know come in and just
stand in front of the judges and the
judges would go
you and you
and that's it
and the rest of them would just go [__]
and walk out of the room
you said that happened to like you know
numerous amount of times wow yeah
[__] crazy also I like how it's these
fashion people who have
probably zero
actual knowledge of
physiology yeah just saying [__] yeah
what a crazy thing less sodium trims
this
oh yeah like that probably doesn't even
that price has nothing to do with it
yeah
it's probably just like genetics would
love to pull up there
assuming you know in this world I'm a
male model
and secretly one of my boys is rolling
with me but they don't know who
and they're like less sodium that will
take care of this and then my boy walks
up and he's like
um actually sodium it's Derek yeah
yeah actually sodium has nothing to do
with stomach
he's just lecturing the whole room I'm
like yeah they're like security
shut the [__] up
he said that I think the funniest story
that he told was that he uh
part of what they had to do sometimes
like I think you know you get chosen for
your look and then you have to walk for
them he said one of the times he started
walking and he synced up his legs and
his arms because he was so nervous
just so funny it's like probably the
only thing
like that's like the number one thing
you shouldn't do probably yeah
yeah I like those like fashion tick
tocks where they'll host a a show
and it'll be on a bridge in New York
you've seen that one no there's one they
had a couple
like shows put on
which is this random little bridge in
New York and people are just standing
in uh it's like a small it's like a
walking bridge it's like small and
people are like lined up all along the
sides and then the models would like
stomp through
in crazy ass clothes it'd be like a
soccer jersey a thong and then boots
yeah yeah this is the one yeah
these are the models I mean anytime I've
seen clips from this free fashion show
whoever's in it is just mobbing
they don't walk gentle or how I think of
models they're like [__] stomping
through
yeah
this one's a bit more elegant yeah
that's that's a oh
[Laughter]
okay oopsie oops
full ass cheek there
oh this one's a bit elevated
it would have been sick she just had
diarrhea okay like that yeah look again
right here that's mobbing through
that see that guy yeah
barreling through
she's laughing she said oh [__] you
about to fight
I kind of like this look at this look at
this there you go that was almost the
shoulder check yeah
there we go that's just straight up
straight jacket
biting yeah I want to do I want to put
on one of these but the models are are
Sprint Runners like former Olympic
sprinters yeah you can't even see the
yeah you gotta like really focus to see
the outfit you're like oh [__] yeah
so it's gone
and it's only one way yeah they just
barely like to Barrel through and
there's just like a short window where
you can see them run through
or they're on like one of those rides
like the Gravitron or whatever yeah
and you're like
yeah yeah like hello no that's it was it